cette vidéo est sponsorisée par displate
avez-vous déjà essayé de poser des
posters sur votre
mur et oui c'est compliqué n'est-ce pas
et vous vous demandez y a-t-il une
solution si vous vous demandez et bien
il y a displate displate ce sont des
posters en métal disponibles en
plusieurs formats en math et en gloss
avec des tas de collections retro gaming
film jeux vidéos bande dessinée et
comics et tout ça s'installe très
simplement grâce au système de montage
magnétique facile et
sûr et voilà le tour est
joué pas très malin ça n'est pas grave
car tous les posters displate sont
repositionnables
oui non c'est pas grave les display sont
produits en Europe et vous seront
envoyés sous 4 à 5 jours ouvrables
collectionnez et partagez vos
grâce à vos posters qui vous serviront
de déclencheur de conversation avec vos
amis en
soirée il est horribleam comment ça
fait et en ce moment profitez de la plus
grande offre du Black Friday avec 44 %
de réduction en utilisant le lien en
description avec de nouvelles
collections Donjons et Dragons Seigneur
des Anneaux Harry Potter et bien
d'autres
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut à tous que vous fassiez du jeu de
rôle ou pas normalement si je vous
demande là tout de suite de me citer un
jeu de rôle sur table le premier que
vous devriez me citer c'est Donjons et
Dragons c'est le maître étalon du jeu de
rôle et même si ce n'est pas le plus
joué c'est très certainement le pilier
du Médiéval Fantay et surtout bah tout
le monde connaît he même ceux qui ne
connaissent pas les jeux de rô
connaissent le nom Donjons et Dragons
vous avez forcément vu dans un film ou
dans une série une scène où il faut se
moquer d'un gronur d' lunette qui a pas
de Copin et qui a un mage noir level 9
sur Donjons et Dragons et ben vous savez
quoi le gronur D' lunette il est devenu
super connu et riche et il vous emmerde
ah bon tu tu le connais et surtout
donjon dragon ça a été le premier jeu de
rô à sortir de sa condition de jeu de rô
pour faire autre chose on avait fait
heroes of the lands he sur NES mais des
jeux Donjons et Dragons il y en a eu
plein d'autres depuis les jeux
électroniques jusqu'au célèbre jeux
Baldur gate plcape tment ou never winter
nights il y a eu aussi des dessins
animés puisqu'on avait déjà parlé he
souvenez-vous du dessin animé le sourire
du dragon avec le générique de Dorothé
don et drag la grande avent et enfin on
a du neuf qui arrive puisqueune série
Donjons et Dragons a été annoncée et
qu'un film doit sortir pour début
2023 c'est fou quand même qu'ils aient
pas pensé à faire un film
avant c'était quoi ça en fait c'était
pour créer un espèce de moment
dramatique de révélation
puis de toute façon on s'en fout enfin
je veux dire les gens on l'ulti de la
vidéo ils savent qu'on va parler des
films effectivement il y a déjà eu des
longs métrages Donjons et Dragons vous
envoyez d'ailleurs un extrait là d'un
film sorti en
90 13
2032 2000 2000 2000
ce attends attends attends ce truc qu'on
est actuellement en train de regarder là
ça c'est sorti en 2000 oui mais c'est un
film de médieval fantasy sorti avant le
Seigneur des Anneaux c'est vrai c'est
vrai du coup c'est vrai qu'en quelque
sorte on peut dire bah qu' qu'ils ont
gagnéin bah bravo les gars après tous
les divers logos des sociétés de
production le film s'ouvre donc sur
depuis longtemps un pays divisé euh il
est gouverné par les mages une élite qui
pratique la magie oh oh oh les gens du
commun ceux qui n'ont pas att attendez
une seconde là ne sont guère plus que
des
esclaves Roger tu peux arrêter de
vapoter devant la caméra s'il te
plaît pardon bref on y retrouve Profion
le M maléfique joué par Jeremy Irons
Profion qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
rajoute comme blague sur un mec qui
s'appelle Profion Profion donc dans son
sous-sol démoniaque qui récupère donc
son sceptre rangé dans sa machine qui
tourne les sceptres tu sais à quoi ça
sert aucune idée mais ça toures super
bien mais en réalité ce sceptre sert à
contrôler les
dragons oh [ __ ] je rappelle que c'est
sorti 1 an avant ça tu n'aimes pas ça
n'est-ce pas tant mieux j'utiliser toute
la rage qui est dans toi
ok est-ce que est-ce que est-ce qu'on
peut parler de ce qu'on vient de voir ou
est-ce qu'on va faire comme si on avait
rien vu là mais malheureusement quelque
chose se passe mal et Profion
accompagné de son fidèle soufifre
d'abodar le [ __ ] de schoup se voit
obligé d'achever cette horrible créature
en 3D
dégueulasse ça c'est la tête qu'a dû
faire le Réal quand il a reçu le premier
planans bref le scénario du film c'est
donc tout un tas d'intrigue politique
donc on y retrouve palpati je veux dire
donc Profion qui essaie de convaincre
les députés d'enlever son septre magique
qui contrôle les dragons à la princesse
Amidala enfin je veux dire pardon Savina
ok parce que oui alors attendez je vous
spoile un peu le film ce person
personnage là et faire tomber avec elle
ce Haut conseil de grétin inutile bah
c'est un méchant mais comment tu as
deviné etcartons la menace d'une
révolution à tout jamais acceptez-vous
de vous soumettre dans ce cas l'heure
n'est-elle pas venue d'agir je sais
pas je crois que je suis un génie parce
que oui bon on peut se moquer du côté
jeu d'acteur façon méchant de dessin
animé de Profion mais bon l'écriture
elle aide pas beaucoup aussi hein les
réformes que je propose sont pour le
bien du peuple tous les sujets de
l'Empire d'ismer doivent avoir le même
droit tous mes sujets doivent être
libres et égaux qu'ils soient gens du
commun ou m mais enfins vous vous rendez
bien compte que la gentillesse c'est
bien mieux que la méchanceté oui après
on va pas se cacher c'est aussi amplifié
par le jeu des acteurs
mon
[Applaudissements]
destin VZ à
moi allez vas dis-lui
dis-lui bref pendant que se déroulent
toutes les intrigues politiques on
découvre enfin le héros joué par Jimmy
Olsen de la série lois Clark et son pote
snail le noir rigolo voilà al soyez pas
vexé c'est littéralement sa seule
fonction dans le film tous deux
s'introduisent dans le château pour
essayer d'aller voler la bibliothèque
des mages histoire de se faire quelques
pièces en profitant de la confusion dans
la cité mais ceux-ci se font surprendre
par une des mages travaillant dans la
tour euh et faire le ménage ou
c'est ça alors et là je fais une petite
pause dans le film pour vous parler des
acteurs et je dois dire je sais pas
lequel est mon préféré est-ce que c'est
Jeremy Irons qui joue comme s'il était
complètement possédé mais pas la
guerre Marlon WANs connu surtout en
France pour scar movie qui joue comme si
c'était un mec de notre époque qui avait
été téléporté dans le monde de denjon et
Dragon c'est drôle où est-ce que c'est
la magicienne qui joue littéralement
comme hermion dans Harry Potter quand
elle avait sa je croyais que vous
partiez je vous en prie il s'agit d'un
ancien
parchemin e donc les acteurs principaux
c'est pas ça du coup on va se contenter
des seconds rôles les étrangers ne sont
pas les bienvenus marquz au fer rouge là
où était votre nez d'accord
[Musique]
ok très bien revenons au film donc les
deux héros sont découverts et arrêtés
par la bibliothécaire super chaude que
tu sais pas encore qu'elle est super
chaude parce qu'elle a des lunettes et
elle a les cheveux attachés ah je suis
soulagé je vous remercierai quand on me
coupera la tête vous pourrez vous serez
moins lait comme ça ils vont baiser
ensemble à la fin hein ils vont baiser
ensemble mais soudainement les hommes de
Profion arrivent pour s'emparer d'un
parchemin qui leur permettrait de
retrouver un autre scepttre qui contrôle
les dragons ils réussissent à s'enfuir
et rencontrent dans leur fuite Hellwood
un nain dans une
poubelleirard dans mon coin poster des
brigades à toutes les entrées et sorties
des égûs mon
oroponiste m'a dit de bien
articuler qui je ne sais pas pour quelle
raison va suivre les héros pendant toute
la suite du film on est partant et
towood je crois que j'ai pas tellement
le choix mais qui es-tu on t'a trouvé
dans une poubelle tu as aucune raison
d'être là bref les héros se réfugient
dans la Cantina mais son dorénavant
poursuivi à la fois par une envoyé par
l'Impératrice et par Damodar
[Musique]
un
instant il me faut la
fille ah [ __ ] ce mec est beaucoup trop
intense ça doit être dur d'être comme ça
tout le
temps je voudrais une baguette pas
tropite le méchant les retrouve mais le
NA renverse une table et une bagarre
générale éclate ce qui permet au héros
de
s'enfuir ok vraiment qu'on m'exlique
comment ça marche mécanisme de BAGAR
générale dans la
tavernes oh ben merde
ouais et d'ailleurs faites pas trop
attention à l'arrière- plan à gauche à
droite à gauche à droite la magicienne
convain donc les deux héros et le nain
de l'aider pour retrouver avant Damodar
un des trois septres du dragon qui
seraiit caché dans un temple mais pour y
entrer il leur faut avant un joyau nommé
l'œil du dragon qui serait lui-même
caché au bout du descape Game à
l'intérieur de la guilde des voleurs les
héros partent donc pour le puits du Fou
afin d'y rencontrer le chef de la guilde
et lui demande de pouvoir s'essayer à
l'épreuve oui mais tu dois être
particulièrement doué pour que cette
précieuse petite chose voyage avec toi
ah les années 90 hein 2000 ah les années
90 hein on a donc toute une petite
séquence avec le voleur du groupe qui
passe les différents pièges qui sentent
bon les décors en cartonp de façon
petitre un fantôme allez hop on y va ene
pour la avant de finalement arriver
devant le joyau quand soudain un
mécanisme se déclenche et le voleur n'a
plus le
temps mais comment va-t-il faire pour
passer ce terrible
piège moi dans le doute je pète des
trucs j'ai
tonamment rien à dire sur ce que je
viens de voir le joyau est retrouvé mais
Damodar le soufifre de Profion arrive et
les retrouve une bagarre éclate dans la
guilde des voleurs les héros parviennent
à s'échapper mais damoda réussit tout de
même à enlever la magicienne ainsi que
le parchemin dont il avait besoin non si
seulement j'avais des pouvoirs magies
bre Damodar l'emmène donc en prison
pourquoi êtes-vous allé à la GU de des
voleur pas le genre d'endroit qu'on
visite par plaisir n'est-ce pas vous
êtes M
vous vous êtes la honte dismè en
conspirant contre l'impératrice pourquoi
est-ce qu'on
fuchotte Damodar commence donc à la
torturer grâce aux écouteurs
dégueulasses que Profion lui a mis dans
le crâne pour le punir de les avoir
laissé s'échapper la première fois et se
ser de ses machins pour aller chercher
uneinformation directement à la
source j' profite pour dire maintenant
devant tous nos abonnés je t'aime plus
que toutes les protines je peux
Damodar obtient donc les renseignements
dont il a besoin il sait qu'il lui
faudra l'œil du dragon pour rentrer dans
la caverne du sceptre il tend donc un
piège aux deux héros qui attaquent le
château pour libérer la magicienne sans
savoir qu'ils sont attendus très bien je
m'occupe de Marina et toi du parchemin
d'accord c'était parfaitement inutile
Ridley c'est le nom de Jimmy Hsen libère
donc la magicienne de sa prison et
commence à fuir le château tandis que
son pote snail qui était parti chercher
le parchemin tombe dans un piège tendu
par Damodar oh non je savais que c'était
trop facile
c'est le fameux sort qui transforme les
tapis en polenta dur placer celui-là je
reconnais bien là les voleur toujours à
prendre ce qui ne leur appartient pas je
reconnais bien là les menuisiers
toujours à faire des meubles avec du
bois
il est fort en définition en plus ce
dernier réussi à s'enfuir avec Damar C
trous mais tombe dans un cul de sac le
duel face à Damodar tourne à son
désavantage mais heureusement le voleur
et la magicienne réussissent à arriver
juste à temps pour sauver SNE non il
[Applaudissements]
meurt ah ouais ah ils ont vraiment fait
le coup du noir qui meurt en premier
bref Ridley et la magicienne s'enfuiti
et rejoignent les F pour se mettre à
l'abri de Profion et de Damodar et
évidemment Ridley vit durement le deuil
de la mort de son ami
enfin il est clairement effondré là ça
se voit ceux qui restent de l'équipe se
rend donc à la caverne magique pour
s'emparer du seceptre mais à part le
voleur un champ de force empêche tout le
monde
d'entrer bon en même temps c'est pas
comme si les autres servaient à rien
depuis le début du film donc c'est pas
bien grave le voleur arrive donc seul
devant la porte du temple du sptre où
l'attend l'énigme la plus compliquée du
monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo incroyable quel génie à
l'intérieur du alors je sais pas trop si
c'est un temple ou le sous-sol de
nemmaus dans lequel d'ailleurs le
concierge est visiblement passé juste
avant par l'entrée de service pour
allumer les lumière le héros arrive et
s'are du sceptre qui contrôle les
dragons des mains de son gardien il
ressort mais à l'extérieur Damodar a
capturé la magicienne merci de m'avoir
épargné cette peine mais c'est un sketch
on a combien tr fois qure fois j'ai
perdu le compte à force ils font quoi
les autres ils sont FK ne lui faites pas
de mal alors donne-moi le
bâton et vous les
relâcherez je te donne ma parole ouais
vas-y t'inquiète c'est clairement un mec
à qui tu peux faire confiance vous
deviez les
relâcher j'ai menti ah merde il nous a
eu Damodar retourne à la capitale pour
donner le bâton à son maître pro qui
pendant ce tempsl est en plein combat
contre une cinématique de PlayStation 2
envoyée par l'impératrice mon Dieu qu je
fais mais le bâton retourne le cours de
la bataille en invoquant les dragons
rouges et en décuplant les talents
d'acteurs de Jérémy iron vous pouvez
vous sauver Majesté mais vous ne vous
sauverez jamais assez loin elle est
bonne vous êtes sûr que vous voulez pas
le faire j'ai dit elle est bonne on a
donc droit à 10 minutes de cinéma
dynamique digne des meilleurs shows du
Futuroscope avant que finalement le
héros V d'amodar en le jetant dans le
vide avant de finalement s'emparer du
bâton des mains de Profion qui meurt en
finissant manger par un de ces
dragons il va me manquer moi Jérémy
irons là dans ce film c'était clairement
le truc le plus intéressant et c'est
fini l'Impératrice est débarrassé de ses
ennemis et peut donc appliquer son
programme électoral peuple
DISM aujourd'hui je peux enfin déclarer
que vous serez désormais tous égau que
les festivités
commencent vous voyez c'est pas dur la
politique chers compatriotes je déclare
que vous êtes tous égau allez on va
manger et le film se finit donc sur la
pierre tombale de snails et ses amis qui
se recueille
devant dites ce type c'est le seul mec
qui est mort pour sauver le royaume on
pourrait pas quand même lui payer une
vraie Pierre Tombal non allez on va
bouffer bon alors ce film est sorti un
an avant le Seigneur des Anneaux produit
d'ailleurs par New Line la même boîte
que pour Lord of the Rings et ce premier
film Donjon et Dragon ça a été un bid d'
intertergalactique mais en même temps
voilà on peut lui trouver des excuses
puisque ce film sort avant le seigneur
des anneaux du coup il y a pas trop de
budget puisque on sait pas si ce genre
de truc ça va plaire aux gens sauf que
le deuxème film Donjon et Dragon il sort
en 2005 entreetemps il y a eu les trois
films seneur Zano donc on sait que ça
plaît aux gens ce genre de truc on sait
que les gens ils veulent voir de l'héroï
fantasy alors s'il vous plaît est-ce
qu'il y a Mo y de nous filer un petit
peu plus de budget pour les effets
spéciaux ça veut dire non c'est ça allez
donc donjons et Dragon 2 un film qui
comme j'ai dit est sorti 2 ans après le
retour du roi bon alors déjà l'animation
du début c'est pas trop dégueulasse il y
a un clin d'œil à une fiche de stat les
dessins sont plutôt jolis ça commence
plutôt
B c'est terrible c'est l'accident après
seulement 12 secondes en piste mon cher
Gilbert oui tout à fait franc on voit
bien que réalisateur a brandi le drapon
rouge
bon tant pis alors on va pas se faire le
film chronologiquement comme pour le
premier en gros Damodar est de retour et
il a arrêter les choupachous M glacial
le globe de falazure est mi vous
rappelez de ce méchant là du film qui a
idée et que personne n'a eu et ben il
est
revenu d'être content non bon alors on
l'a vu avec les effets spéciaux le
budget est visiblement pas là non plus
on peut dire que certaines scènes
manquent de décor un peu monsieur j'ai
trouvé qu'une seule épée pour le
décor j'en sais rien moi mais foutez-moi
ça au mur et c'est le premier problème
de ce film il y a pas une tune tout à
l'air faux au début du film les
personnages vont dans une caverne tout
fait faux les murs ont l'air faux le
plafond à l'air faux les effets spéciaux
pour la magie sont à chiier regardez on
dirait qu'ils sont dans le sous-sol du
château de la belleie d'ormand à 10 de
Paris là et d'ailleurs globalement tout
ce second film donjons à Dragon a
vraiment une esthétique de film de boule
plus tard ils vont rencontrer d'autres
personnages et toutes les meufs sont
toutes toutes maquillées elles sont
toutes propre même la barbare elle est
toute jolie toute pomponnée VO alors le
scénario j'ai dû aller le voir sur le
net je suis désolé mais c'est impossible
de se concentrer sur ce que disent les
personnages pendant la scène
d'exposition pendant toute la scène qui
explique l'intrigue il y a ce mec
derrière qui est complètement sur une
autre planète c'est impossible de se
concentrer sur ce que dit la meuf avec
ce mec en
arrière-pl pouvoir dans un globe
noir il
est en plus az-v vu bon alors comme j'ai
absolument rien suivi je suis allé voir
sur Wikipédia et en gros le scénario du
film c'est que les héros vont devoir
aller récupérer le globe de falasure qui
est un artefact qui permet de réveiller
et de contrôler les dragons et qui est
en la possession de dambodar on va donc
suivre toute une équipe de héros composé
de différentes classes qu'on peut
trouver dans le jeu donjour et dragons
paladin voleur m Barbar et cetera qui
part donc pour trouver des Gobelins afin
d'obtenir des renseignements sur
l'emplacement du globe de falassure tu
ne pourrais pas nous téléporter sur
place comme je ne suis mes allé à
kururtle je ne peux pas visualiser
l'endroit ah je vois qu'elle a pas
débloqué le voyage rapide et ce film est
très différent du premier film dans Jan
dragon hein déjà les personnages ne se
rencontrent pas naturellement par le
déroulement du scénario mais sont plutôt
assemblés par un espèce de montage de
recrutement en mode expandable un peu
genre il nous faut quoi un prêtre check
une magicienne check et c'est bizarre
mais au final ça ressemble beaucoup plus
à une vraie partie de jeux rôle où très
souvent pour des raisons pratiques on
fait commencer ensemble des personnages
qui pourtant ne se connaissent pas entre
eux et donc benah comme un vrai jeu de
rô finalement on a tout un tas de petits
moments secondaires qui ne servent à
rien dans le scénario à part faire du
remplissage pour faire plaisir au fan
hardcore qui reconnaîtront les rês
Ilb je vois elle a utilisé mur de flamme
sort de conjuration level 4 de la classe
de ma habile mais quand est-ce qu'on BAE
merde bref tout ça pour dire que je vais
me contenter juste de parler des trucs
qui font avancer l'histoire principale
celle du globe de falassure alors que
l'équipe approche du but pour trouver la
crypte qui contient je sais pas quel
objet magique à la con qui leur
permettrait de se téléporter chez
Damodar soudain ils se font prendre en
embuscade par les troupes ennemis des
Brigant c'est certainement encore un
cadeau de Damodar la bataille s'engage
alors et cette bataille je voulais vous
en parler parce que c'est une des pires
batailles que j'ai vu de ma vie je veux
dire ok là la barbare est en train de se
battre contre les brigandes donc ça veut
dire qu'ils sont arrivés en bas mais non
on les voit courir sur absolument tous
les plans non parce qu'il y avait qu'une
seule ligne d'ennemi en haut et là ils
sont de nouveau super loin sur tous les
plans ils sont en train de descendre de
la colline pourtant je sais pas c'est
une petite colline il devrait être AR à
force ils font quoi là c'est quand il
arrivent en bas ils remontent ou
quoi et regardez il y a des mecs qui
cour avec des arcs c'est génial ils ont
même pas compris le principe des arcs ah
non mais sans déconner moi j'adore cette
bataille c'est une œuvre d'art bref les
héros trouve l'artefact qui leur permet
de se téléporter dans le repère du
méchant mais attention la bille toboggan
activé et hop un saut de trempelin
souris piégé ouf c'est pas moi gagné
nouveau jeu attrape souris
heureusement les héros réussissent à se
libérer à couper le bras de dabodar qui
s'enfuit et repartent pour ichmir la
capitale avec l'orbe magique de
falassure qu'ils étaient venus récupérer
tandis que Damodar lui pense ses
bless mais [ __ ] mais mais vous êtes
sérieux mais Monseigneur je vois bien
que votre bras est derrière votre dos là
si il est coupé j'ai pas de bras non il
est pas vraiment coupé non si j'ai
croisé des gentils et même ils m'ont
coupé le bras non mais [ __ ] mais c'est
qui lui là c'est quoi c'est une race de
Donjons et Dragons ça ou c'est le
crocodil deppu bamstrade bon alors donc
comme j'ai dit les héros reviennent à la
capitale avec l'orbe mais un des
soufifre du méchant qui avait pris
l'apparence d'un démage s'empare de
l'artefact et s'envole pour le rendre à
Damodar
[ __ ] oh
ou là ou là ou
là ok merci pour cette petite bouboule
mais je vais pas faire comme si j'avais
pas vu ton arrivée là à nouveau en
possession de l'Orbe d'amodar peut donc
invoquer dégueulass or le roi des
dragons dégueulasses celui-ci attaque la
ville mais heureusement les héros
réussissent à trouver un autre artefact
magique de mes couilles pour le
repousser
ouais s'il pouvait retrouver la
maquilleuse aussi au passage ouais c'est
vrai que le maquillage est dégueulasse
ils aurait dû mettre un filtre VHS ouais
le dragon est donc repoussé il ne reste
plus qu'à aller chercher Damodar seul
sur sa colline dans son plan qui pue la
tristesse la vache après une course
poursuite à cheval la barbare qui était
inopinément sur le trajet la course
poursuite se jette devant lui et le
desésarsonne je vois elle a utilisé le
sort de je me place sur le trajet du
scénario invocateur level
8 L
divine maman ce qui permet au héros de
rattraper d' modard et de l'arrêter le
avec cette chose qui n'est clairement
pas un vrai couteau et c'est la fin du
film ah tiens d'amard il s'appelle Bruce
pain le célèbre patman alors bon il y
aura bien un troisème film Donjon et
Dragon mais qui est loin d'être aussi
intéressant que les deux premiers en
fait le premier Donjon et Dragon aussi
mauvais
soit-il ils ont quand même essayé de
faire un film certes ils ont fait des
raccourcis ils ont pas forcément
respecté le l mais ils ont quand même
essayé alors que ce deuxième et ce
troisème film ressemble davantage à une
partie de jeux de rôle qu'on aurait mise
en vidéo avec tous les trucs chiants que
tu retrouves dans les JdR aussi
d'ailleurs dans ce cas je vais prendre
un anneau de force un sac de sortie
d'ège paralysant une épée des belles
factures et cette armure de Che ça est
modèle vertueux ou héroïque vertueux
attendez c'est quoi le problème là
bordel y a bien toutes les conneries de
votre jeu là les lutins les princesses
les magiciens qu'est-ce que vous êtes
pas content et ce côté vraiment bizarre
est aussi renforcé par le fait que les
personnages parlent d'avantage comme des
joueurs de jeux de rôle que comme des
personnages qui vivraient vraiment dans
cet univers je n'ai que deux sortes de
téléportation à réserve ah je peux pas
ouvrir cette bouteille je n'ai pas assez
de dextérité bon alors bref je vais pas
forcément parler en de ce trè film mais
pourtant ils ont vraiment forcé très
très fort pour rendre ça intéressant
pour les
[Musique]
spectateur dominemoi ah ils ont vraiment
beaucoup forcé donc au final en trois
films on aura eu un nard et de navé mais
il se trouve que l'année prochaine et
bien un autre film Donjons et Dragons va
sortir avec un trailer qui pu bien la
comédie façon gardien de la galaxie sur
ce Moyen-Âge mais bon allez on va lui
laisser une chance et peut-être qu'on
aura enfin une bonne surprise
bon ok tu vas me rendre ça ça n'est pas
fait pour toi don drag la grand
aventure la Raon d'étranges créatures
des monbres de terreur au ordres de
vengeur guerre contre le mal pour un
idéal Donjons et Dragons sur une planète
derrière l'horizon seul le grand maître
connaî t less qui feront Triomph
l'espoir et la pouréter
Donjons et Dragons sur une planète
derrière l'horizon où seul le grand
maître connaî tous les secret qui feront
triompher l'espoir et la paix au nom de
l'amié
[Musique]